sandus donors privately worry about
campaign as Florida Governor lags in
2024 polls they say some of Rhonda
tennis's fundraisers have recently heard
concerns up from donors about the
trajectory of his campaign the governor
continues to lag Trump in GOP Primary
polls Ken Griffin the billionaire CEO of
Citadel and previous Santa's Mega donor
continues to assess the field a growing
excuse me group of donors who have
supported DeSantis run are worried about
the trajectory of his campaign even
after he raked in 20 million dollars
despite those big fundraising numbers
and his entry into the race on a wave of
hype DeSantis is lagging well behind
front-runner Donald Trump
so they're going to basically make a lot
of the same points
nothing's changed and Griffin's stance
toward the election we have this from
the post-millennial they say DeSantis to
meet with major donors to face questions
about campaign viability this is coming
from Charles gasparino Fox Business
Rhonda said is planning to meet major
East Coast owners next week at a private
gathering in Southampton he faces
questions about viability of his
campaign as he stalled in the polls